bonsoir il est 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur TVfil 78 durant
1 heure nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité locale en compagnie d'invité
à commencer par Daniel taravellaa
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
Fédération française du bâtiment dans le
département des Yvelines votre secteur
se porte plutôt mal victime de la crise
depuis plus plusieurs mois et depuis ce
matin un nouveau sujet d'inquiétude la
hausse de la contribution foncière des
entreprises cette taxe qui a remplacé en
2009 la taxe professionnelle va cette
année doubler tripler on parle même de
800 % de hausse sur certains secteurs
tout d'abord en quoi cela concerne le
département et puis en quoi cela
concerne le bâtiment également que vous
représentez ça concerne le bâtiment
puisque ça concerne toutes les
entreprises quel qu'elle soit je vous
rappellerai simplement que lorsque l'on
a supprimé la taxe professionnel
certains se sont émus en disant que
c'était encore un cadeau aux entreprises
B on constate aujourd'hui que le cadeau
est un petit peu empoisonné
puisqueencore une fois on s'aperçoit
effectivement qu'il y a des
augmentations extrêmement importantes et
juste avant de venir j'ai signé un
certain nombre de courriers à
destination des députés des sénateurs et
des maires des ivelines pour attirer
leur attention et pour envisager
éventuellement une possibilité de
d'amender ces ces avec cette hausse donc
pour l'instant de la contribution
foncière des entreprises sauf changement
dans les prochaines semaines on verra si
l'action vous menez le lobbying en tout
cas que vous mener actuellement portera
ses fruits nous allons parler justement
de cette situation dans le bâtiment ce
soir plus de détails dans un instant
voici déjà les principaux titres du jour
les sujets à retrouver au cours de cette
édition du 78 de ce 21 novembre en imag
les premiers rendez-vous organisés
autour de la rider Cup 2018 la
prestigieuse compétition internationale
de golf ne se tiendra que dans 6 ans à
50 ans en nubline mais dès hier les
licenciés étaient invités à venir tester
le parcours de nuit les marmitons la
cuisine centrale de la ville de trappe
entièrement rénovée l'objectif est aussi
d'apprendre aux enfants à mieux mieux
manger vous le verrez tout à l'heure
l'exposition rectoverso se concentre sur
les années 1900 à Versailles Versailles
qui se concentre et qui se raconte par
les cartes postal c'est au domaine de
Madame ellisabeth jusqu'au 3 février et
plus qu'un concours un véritable
spectacle Les hip hop games se sont
installé à guillancour il y a quelques
jours rendez-vous proposé dans le cadre
du festival des pulsations urbaines qui
se tient actuellement dans l'ensemble de
l'agglomération cquentinoise et puis
nous sommes mercredi le mercredi c'est
le jour de la chronique culture avec
Joanna sououdri bonsoir Joanna bonsoir
vulfri bonsoir à tous nous parlerons
ensemble de thâtre et de solidarité avec
un comédien venu du Sénégal qui jouera à
plaisir et puis nous découvrirons la
nouvelle exposition de Guille en cours
autour du cinéma ce sera donc dans une
vingtaine de minutes tout à l'heure sur
cette antenne cette chronique culture la
la phrase du jour à présent elle est
signée François Hollande le président
lors du congrès des maires de France qui
à propos du mariage pour tous a déclaré
mardi la loi s'applique pour tous dans
le respect néanmoins de la liberté de
conscience évquant aussi les
possibilités de délégation d'un maire à
ses adjoints qui existent et qui peuvent
être élargis pour célébrer de tels
mariages il est revenu par
l'intermédiaire de son entourage sur ses
propos il y a quelques heures seulement
cette phrase a déjà provoqué la colère
d'une partie des élus en France a
commencé par Eddie ha le maire du Parti
radical gauche à carrière souspoissie
par un communiqué ce matin il a expliqué
que cette déclaration est
incompréhensible elle constitue une
remise en cause du principe
constitutionnel de neutralité du service
public il invite les maires à se
rassembler pour proclamer fermement leur
attachement et leur engagement à
respecter les principes démocratiques
qui fondent la République française le
golf de Saint-Quentin en yeline se
prépare donc à accueillir la rider Cup
en 2018 composition compétition pardon
qui oppose les Américains aux Européens
qui se déroulera à 50 ans en Eveline des
animations pour fédérer notamment les
licenciés autour de ce grand rendez-vous
sont déjà organisés notamment hier soir
ils sont invités à découvrir le parcours
de nuit
regardez le swing à la lampe frontale
avec une balle clignotante une
expérience inédite au golf national en
vue de la rider Cup 2018 et des
sensations pour le moins perturbante
pour ses licenciés pourtant joueur AG
guéri du ferway du c'est assez
surprenant
les sensations sont totalement
différentes la perception du de la
géographie du terrain est
absolument impossible à à avoir et donc
on joue un petit peu un petit peu à
l'aveugle les repères s'en vont le point
d'arrivée reste dans l'obscurité et même
les plus courtes distances comme au
putting s'avère très tortueuse pour les
plus frileux un simulateur de Drive
était aussi installé dans le club house
les participants pouvaient aussi
s'essayer au swing virtuel sur les
consoles de jeux vidéo mais rien ne vaut
le club dans la main c'est plus
difficile de jouer à la console pour moi
mais je pense que aussi jouer de nuit là
comme on l'a fait pour la première fois
c'est pas du tout simple c'est très
amusant
mais bon c'est quand même il faut il
faut être habitué c'est dès maintenant
que la rider Cup se prépare au Golf
National plus de 6 millions d'euros sont
prévu pour aménager le parcours et le
rendre plus spectaculaire un parcours
que devrai fouler les joueurs français
après le titre mondial chez les amateurs
en
2010 la mission qui leur est donné par
le comité directeur et par moi bien sûr
c'est dire les enfants on a la rider Cup
mais si on a pas de français dans
l'équipe européenne il y en a que 12
membres c'est une équipe raid les
meilleurs
européens on aura raté quelque chose en
attendant d'avoir un Français dans
l'équipe européenne en 2018 certains
risquent de jouer jusqu'au bout de la
nuit
le premier invité qui nous accompagne
donc ce soir c'est le président de la
Fédération française du bâtiment dans le
département des iblines vous nous disiez
tout à l'heure être inquiet pour votre
secteur notamment avec la hausse de
cette contribution foncière des
bâtiments qui touche les entreprise ce
n'est pas le seul sujet d'inquiétude le
département va perdre en 2012 1300
emplois 35000 dans l'ensemble de la
France comment vous expliquer une telle
situation une telle écatombe bien alors
il y a plusieurs explications la
première qui ne laisse pas d'être
inquiétante et qui est en ce sens que
nous nous apercevons que depuis le début
de l'année nous avons plus d'entreprises
qui cessent leur activité volontairement
que d'entreprisees qui la cessent du
fait d'un dépôt de bilan ça signifie
simplement que nos chefs
d'entrepris jettent l'éponge et n'ont
plus envie de de continuer dans le
contexte actuel puisqu'il y a toujours
un maximum de contraintte de charges qui
augmentent et tout ça ce n'est pas fait
pour les séréniser je vous rappelle en
effet que dans notre département mais
c'est vrai aussi pour toute la France
les entreprise du bâtiment à 80 % sont
des moins de 10 donc ce sont de petites
structures et ces entrepreneurs encore
une fois s'arrête parce que le jeu n'en
veut plus la chandelle maintenant il y a
aussi une récession au niveau des
marchés c'est-à-dire que nous avons
moins de marchés c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
moins d'affaires qui sortent et euh si
les entreprises jusqu'à présent ce sont
ont toujours efforcé de conserver leur
personnel force de constater que
actuellement elles envisagent très
sérieusement de licencier ce qui n'était
pas encore le cas l'année dernière et
aujourd'hui nous avons donc des
entreprises qui cessent leur activité
des entreprises qui licencient un autre
élément qui décourage un petit peu ce
sont le problème des de la concurrence
que j'appellerai moi de la concurrence
déloyales ce sont des entreprises
étrangères qui en voit du personnel en
déplacement dans un délai de de de pour
une période plus exactement inférieure à
6 mois ce qui leur permet de bénéficier
des lois sociales de leur pays d'origine
donc là on parle de concurrence au sein
même de l'Europe ou au-delà des
frontières européennes bah moi je parle
pour la France et pour et pour les
Yvelines donc et ce sont effectivement
des entreprises je pense qu'on peut le
dire des entreprises polonaises des
entreprises portugaises également or
aujourd'hui vous avez dans notre
département dans notre département des
entreprises qui vendent leurs heures 17
€ alors que disons pour que une
entreprise normalement structuré
aujourd'hui qui paye toutes ses charges
qui respectent la législation doit
vendre ses heures entre 60 et 70 voire
75 € pour avoir une marge bénéficiaire
de l'ordre 10 pres 60 à 70 € d'écart
vous demandez quoi une une
régularisation de cette situation au
niveau européen peut-être des lois qui
protèger les état au Milie de il y a un
problème il y effectivement je pense un
problème de de réglementation européenne
à revoir et ce qui est aussi ce qui
convient aussi de silial c'est que l'on
s'aperçoit que certaines grandes
entreprises certaines entreprises de
service public soustraite également à
ces entreprises étrangères dans ce qui é
de même un petit peu paradoxal vous
demandz que l'État soit peut-être plus
vigilant et en tout cas fasse attention
à la main d'œuvre qui est embauché sur
les chantiers en tout cas chaque fois
que chaque fois que je rencontre des des
élus effectivement je force de signaler
la chose et je leur demande
effectivement de réfléchir et j'ai eu
quelques réactions disant que ils
allaient effectivement intervenir pour
essayer de faire modifier la
réglementation au début de votre
intervention tout à l'heure de votre
réponse vous avez mentionné ces ces
départs volontaires cette cessation
d'activité volontaire aujourd'hui la la
profession dans le bâtiment est abatue
baisse les bras on préfère déposer le
bilan ne pas attendre de déposer le
bilan pardon et et d à présent mettre la
clé sous la porte et partir passer à
autre chose bah c'est exactement cela et
c'est bien ce qui est inquiéant c'est
cet état d'esprit là aujourd'hui
absolument alors qu'encore une fois les
entrepreneurs par définition ont un un
esprit d'entreprise donc ont l'habitude
de se battre mais aujourd'hui encore une
fois les contraintes sont extrêmement
importantes tous les jours on leur crée
on leur on les met dans l'obligation de
faire suivre des stages supplémentaires
à leur personnel qui laisse d'ailleurs
quelquefois même supposer que nous avons
des des des salariés qui sont un petit
peu dédemeurés parce que il faut un
stage obligato pour monter un
échafaudage un stage obligatoire pour
marcher sur l'échafaudage un stage
obligatoire pour travailler à proximité
d'une prise de courant enfin toutes
choses qui qui paraissent un petit peu
démentes qui se traduisent par des
journées de travail donc de production
en moins qui se traduisent par des coûts
en plus parce que ces stages sont bien
évidemment payants donc tout ceci
s'ajoute à cela également c'est que les
entrepreneurs s'aperçoivent que les
affaires ne sont plus rentable parce que
bon le problème des prix dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure le problème des
délais de paiement qui est extrêmement
aigu c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui en
principe le délai de paiement est de 30
jours depuis la loi LME aussi bien pour
les marchés privés que pour les marchés
publics or en marché public on
s'aperçoit que les délais réels sont de
l'ordre de 60 90 voire beaucoup plus je
peux même vous citer vous travaillez la
livraison a lieu et l'entrepreneur est
payé 3 mois plus tard oui même plus que
ça je peux même vous citer des exemples
extrêmement précis sans donner le nom
des entreprises mais euh une entreprise
des Yvelines qui a une vingtaine de
personnes qui a fait récemment un
chantier pour la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 an en Yveline et
bien aujourd'hui elle attend encore le
paiement de facture qui remonte au mois
de février et de mars donc vous voyez
que ça fait 9 mois au lieu de 30 jours
ce qui est extrêmement important donc
vous nous dites que c'est la communauté
d'agglomération de cant anine qui na pas
réglé ses factures tout à fait tout à
fait autre autre exemple euh ces
derniers temps vous avez vu que les
médias se sont apitoyés un petit peu sur
le sort d'un maire qui n'était pas de
notre qui n'est pas de notre département
mais un maire qui a fait la greffe de la
fin pour obtenir des crédits si j'en
parle c'est parce que l'une des
entreprises il y a une entreprise
ivelinoise qui est dans ce giron et qui
n'est pas payée qui est en train de
faire des chantiers sur lesquels elle
n'a pas touché un centime ce qui me
surprend c'est que les médias n'ont pas
du tout réfléchi au fait que ce maire
c'est ne s'est pas comporté très
honorablement parce qu'il n'aurait
jamais dû passer de commande en
l'absence de fonds disponi donc il est
allé un petit peu à l'aventure et
aujourd'hui ce sont les entreprises qui
jouent les banquiers de la ville de
sevrant pour ne pas la nommer voilà pour
ces exemples précis que vous avez
mentionné bien évidemment le droit de
réponse s'applique hein pour les les
dossiers que vous avez mentionné on va
juste faire une petite pause puisque le
souci he forcément c'est aussi le le
manque de chantier ne serait-ce que du
côté du du prix pr nous avons voulu
savoir si les habitants des ivelines de
50 ans eneline trouv facile ou non de
faire construire est-ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire construire en ce moment regarde
de la crise on les
écoute je pense qu'il est assez
difficile de faire construire sa région
surout sa maison en région parisienne du
fait de la du manque de terrain
constructible en fait tout simplement je
pense que c'est difficile vous pouvez
commencer à à faire construire une
maison et puis que que les entrepreneurs
mettent la clé sous la porte parce que
aujourd'hui les banques ne donnent pas
cette opportunité milieu de travail
enfin il y a beaucoup points négatifs
que positifs en fait vu qu'il faut
énormément d'argent et que aujourd'hui
avec la crise c'est pas possible tous
les revu que je que je suis en train de
consulter bah tout simplement parce que
je pense que ça va être très difficile
pour moi de construire avec tout
l'argent que j'ai enfin avec tout ce
qu'on gagne ça fait déjà un an que je
que je que j'ai commencé à penser mais
ça va encore être dur
voilà c'est pas l'envie qui manque de se
lancer dans la construction de son
pavillon par exemple mais derrière ça
coûte cher et la situation économique
est telle que forcément ensuite les
entreprises du du bâtiment sont
concernées la situation devrait
s'aggraver hein avec cette TVA qui va
augmenter on parle d'un taux à 10 % ça
serait le nouveau taux intermédiaire
quelle conséquence vous souhaitez
retourner là cétait à 7 % actuellement
ça passerait à 10 % en 1er janvier 2014
vous souhaiteriez que on retourne qu'on
passe à 5 % seulement bien évidemment
bien évidemment le soit des entreprises
ce serait effectivement de revenir à à à
5 % parce que c'est un un un créneau qui
permet tout de même aux gens de faire
beaucoup de travaux d'entretien il est
bien évident que si l'on augmente la TVA
la tentation du travail noir va être
beaucoup plus pressante et et plus
importante et effectivement aujourd'hui
on nous dit que ma fois entre 7 et 10 %
n'y a que TR points cela étant il faut
tout de même réfléchir à ce que vous
venez de dire à savoir Queau 1er janvier
nous étions à 5 et5 % et lorsque nous
serons à 10 c'est-à-dire que le taux
aura doublé bien évidemment c'est au
premier janvier 2014 c'est-à-dire que
tout au cours de l'année 2013 nous
allons rester à 7 % on peut m'avz dit en
préparant l'entretien c'est qu' un effet
prime à la casse en fait c'est un petit
peu ça c'est que les gens vont se ruer
en tout cas faire le maximum de travaux
l'année prochaine avant l'augmentation
1er janvier 2014 tout MOS on pe
l'imaginer on peut l'imaginer mais il
est bien évident que les travaux qui
vont être anticipés en 2013 ne seront
plus à faire en 2014 et donc çaa
effectivement exactement le même le même
impact qu'on avait eu la la prime à la
care pour les automobiles une dernière
question vous avez rencontré plusieurs
élus du Département des sénateurs des
sénatrices des députés également vous
allez rencontrer prochainement aussi
David Douillet qui siège dans
l'opposition député UMP de la 12e
circonscription du du département des
ivelines vous avez le sentiment que vous
allez être entendu en tout cas que vos
espoirs que les espoirs que vous portez
vont aboutir qu'il y aura des
réalisations concrètes des amendements
des modifications de loi ça semble
compliqué au regard du contexte
économique oui alors ce que je voudrais
dire c'est qu'effectivement
systématiquement nous prenons contact
chaque fois que un problème se pose nous
en contact avec tous les élus du
Département des tous les sénateurs ou
tous les députés ce que je dois dire
c'est qu'effectivement j'ai pu
rencontrer Monsieur poisson qui est
député à
rambouill Monsieur Arnaud Richard que
j'ai eu des contacts avec Madame duchen
avec Monsieur Miard avec Monsieur Gueno
et que je dois effectivement rencontrer
Monsieur douillet dans dans 8 10 jours
mais ce que je déplore c'est que nous
n'arrivons pas à rencontrer un seul élu
de la majorité gouvernementale actuelle
et Dieu sait que nous avons des n
d'opposition effectivement du côté voà
Dieu sait que nous leur avons écrit que
nous avons même eu des courriers nous
disant qu'il se tenaient à notre
disposition mais lorsque nous
téléphonons pour obtenir un rendez-vous
on nous promet de répondre mais jusqu'à
présent je n'ai jamais rien eu depuis le
mois de mai impossible d'établir un
contact concret avec un élu de la
majorité actuelle on verra si votre
passage en plateau a réussi à changer
les chos chose merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau merci pour ces précisions le
secteur du bâtiment vous l'avez compris
qui est en pleine crise à travers la
France et bien sûr dans le département
des ivelines un ce chiffre pour 2012300
suppression de poste dans le département
concernant le secteur du bâtiment à
suivre ce soir la chronique culture avec
Johanna sououdri pour l'instant
direction les marmitons c'est la cuisine
centrale de la ville de trappentièrement
rénovée l'objectif est aussi d'apprendre
là-bas aux enfants à mieux s'alimenter à
mieux
manger la cuisine centrale de trappe
fait peau neuve c'est ici que sont
préparés les repas des écoliers de la
ville les marmitons une cuisine pensée
comme un véritaable outil pour apprendre
à mieux manger nous voulons garder la
maîtrise entière sur la fabrication des
des menus pour les enfants parce que
nous avons développé en parallèle le
côté éducatif de l'équilibre alimentaire
en effet les menus sont élaborés avec
une diététicienne qui forme également
les animateurs scolaires à cette
problématique la ville de trappe a signé
une charte de l'Association nationale
des restaurateurs de collectivité le
document élaboré en 1998 vise à faire
reconnaître la qualité de la
restauration publique territoriale la
qualité des produits de l'accueil et du
service en Sal et prise en compte mais
aussi la bonne gestion du budget de la
cuisine si on a des cuisines
surdimensionnées c'est des frais
d'entretien de maintenance important et
c'est aussi un amortissementonarrivera
jamais à gérer prochaine initiative de
la cuisine municipale
le tri sélectif des déchets par les
enfants eux-mêmes et le recyclage des
barquettes